hello and welcome everyone to another
Android developer lab plus we will be
getting started in just a minute I'm
just setting up the Google developers
live link so just bear with us and we'll
be right back yeah everyone
okay and we're good to go so if you're
tuning in online live right now then you
should be able to go to
developers.google.com / live and go to a
dl plus so let's start off with the
usual introductions I am Ankur Kotwal
and I'm joining you from Sydney
Australia I'm also joined by my
colleague and friend hi I'm Tony Chan
are from tony is muted right now so we
can't hear him but he will fix that up
in a second okay hey can you hear me now
are we still can't hear them so let me
introduce Tony in the meanwhile there's
tony chen from hong kong and however one
of our regular viewers andrew has just
joined us with as well hi Andrew oh ok
ah alright Tony I cannot Android you
able to hear Tony can you hear me now we
end up yes yeah right oh yeah so I am
Tony Tan joining the Hangout from hong
kong so today we have the special topic
for today is density independently so
and before that our lab let's are many
share share my screen hopefully this
time we would we do you do it right ah
then give me a second
so can everyone see the sly all right
yep looks good he attorney okay I'll so
let's talk about on before we get a
catheter then the D key subject today
let's talk about news um so for this
week we have ATT 21 TV 03 is mostly bug
fixes and no new feature but if you want
to check it out as always like just go
to tools and joy calm another news this
week is our colleague Roman Nurik has
made the cheapest post about chips in
recipient text field so this is what you
you guys usually see on the Google+ a
client and Roman has some details
information about how way you think at
the curl from the AOSP website so check
that out i have a google shan ling here
so can check your precious did it just
to give you a background on that we call
it chips but it's basically when you
when you complete some contact
information rather than have the email
address or the phone number show up you
get a nice little rectangular box with
an image of the avatar of that person in
that box and their name so instead of
having just a static email address it's
a it's a much more pleasant piece of you
I and you can you know select that whole
chip if you want to clear it or if you
want to add a few more people drag it
around that sort of thing so it's just a
just a nice bit of polish to add to your
apps and those are the little subtle
differences that that really make your
appt stand out compared to two others so
Roman has basically in his post showing
you where you can find it in the android
open source project so the source code
is already there he's just showing you
exactly where to look
cool all right so let's get to the topic
of today our density independent pixel
so before we get to the the details of
what that is and what DP is this start
with an overview on to just get everyone
on the same page with some definitions
so on screen size uh is actually the
physical size of any devices I need
android devices so we have four
categories are small normal large and
extra large and then when we talk about
screen density is really the is the
quantity of pixel width in a physical
area of the screen so um and a lot of
people use that dot per inch this is the
common terminology and for resolution is
closely related to screen density but is
really talking about the total number of
physical pixel on the screen so is when
we talk about screen density and
resolution is really there in
proportional so the higher the screen
density the higher the resolution so so
what is the problem with pixel um
because like as you guys are already
know we introduced something called deep
density independent pixel in n joy and
we highly recommend everyone when did
when you design layout using DPS up so
what is really the problem with pixel
well turn out thanks I'll have many
meanings and what I'm what I really mean
by that is like let's go to the pixel by
the definition of pixel is really based
on a contraction of X which is coming
from picture and the eeo is coming from
element so is really element of the
smallest addressable element of it for
display but then when we talk about
printer our pixel can be a an ink
droplet or you
union or carbon particles so as you can
see the many different meanings based on
the context and the in-camera pixel is
really represent an image sensor element
so so is really am given meaning depends
on determined our technology on all
contacts pixel F and also have different
size and representation because a pixel
in the CRT monitor is different from a
pixel of my LCD screen so if you wanted
to know more about the detail of pixel
unit you can go to Wikipedia to follow
even more detail so now we have a
density independent pixel so the key
here is DP is really a physical length
unit so um just like centimeter or meter
so if it had a physical length in in the
real world um and of course like one
thing we in in the very beginning we use
actually the IP as a shorthand but then
now is the DP and the IPS from
interchangeable and and you can still
find things in in your layout with both
shorthand think so is also a physical
point but then it doesn't have a fixed
dimension so it varies depends on a
technology and how how how how how a
particular device letting her it could
have many pixel in the same like length
so we have a definition or a formula to
transfer the translate between pixel and
DP and and in the former is here is a
pixel is equivalent to DP side times the
TPI over 160 and 160 is really like the
kind of the magic number is because it
is that that's the
and the density for MVP I so in in
Android we have different screen
densities are listed here below here
it's L kiki-ing PIH TBI etc um and the
1i highlight inbred the TB TB is
particularly inserting interesting at
the moment because this is the well
first of all is the TBI for cuoco TV and
and also as well as like it's on the
latest android couplet necessary density
as well so now after we learn all these
like concept let's get to some exercise
so um so how many pixels are there in 1
DP for our first android film the g1
phone in someone make a guess um turns
out the answer is 1 pixel and the reason
is we use the g one as the bait as the
bait is baseline for everything
basically the g1 phone is as the normal
is a normal on screen size and also have
the MVP MVP I resolution sorry for the
typo there let's get to another exercise
so how many pixels are there in one TP
or xhdpi device guess what the answer it
it depends because 48 xhdpi is that is
actually it's a range and in in most
cases a HTTP I is 320 but but but it
depends on what device and could be a
some device could be half life 3 25 more
things like that and so so that's why it
depends and that actually makes this
coming exercise easy because now
um I specify the density of this sh t di
device to 320 and of course the answer
here is to pixel oh ok so another
exercise so what are the dimensions in
DP for the following rectangle so if you
look at the these are rectangles and if
you remember our definition of of a DP
which is a live I actually put the
formula up there for convenience and if
you remember on the MDP is the baseline
which is 160 ah the answer is will be
obvious and the answer is for DP and
because we are in for the for the
rectangle for the MTP I we have four
pixels of on each side and and and
because that's the baseline and we have
four pixels and the answer and then that
makes the answer for DP okay so um
another thing I want to talk about is
the DPI ratio because as you can see
from the formula is really the current
density of your device / 160 and and
because of the and there are actually
ratio between all these different
density and just a just a convenient
thing to remember this slide is 3 24 26
28 so you can use on this ratio easily
to do the proper conversion to get a
pixel or DPS are based on these logic
ratios okay so let's talk about the
problem of using pixel r PX in your in
your layout so here is an example
of the effect of divining a two-by-two
box in pixel in your layout so as you
can see if you do if you define
something are with pixel in the LDP I
device it occupies the entire rectangle
but in but as as you move to different
devices you see the graph are the box
actually is shrinking because you define
things in pixel and and in the higher
density device the pixel is actually
smaller and that's the reason why things
are not scaled properly in in when you
define things in pixel so now let's take
a look at about the effect when you
define things in DP so in this case
because you define on things in DP and
as I mentioned before and hopefully you
already remember DP is a fee is a
physical or length unit so if you define
something a2dp on the representation
across different resolution is the same
is going to be same um and that's and
that's what we we meant by a resolution
independent ok so what about big big map
assets so the android framework actually
is quite intelligent and it will scale
bitmapped Horrible's appropriately when
using DP but there's a big caveat here
um the this the graphics here is as you
can see if you um it doesn't matter
whether you are scaling up or scaling
down um because there's no Edward from
actually a perfect algorithm do we
produce two scowling images
so if you scale up you will because you
don't have enough information you have
to do interpolation and that will create
an image that is not sharp and but at
the same time if you're scaling down
your your image our there's a potential
running into something called aliasing
which also can make your image not sharp
as a tall as also so the conclusion here
is you should create the map piece of
resources from each type of density of
device you're targeting on so what is st
because besides TP there is also SP in
android so SP is something we designed
specifically for text um in the android
framework there is a accessibility
option to allow user to enlarge phones
even they are specifying defeat so in
that case um the formula is really SP is
really DP times some scaling factor
determined by the user uh what kind of
on the scale they want to scale their
phones to the larger ones or smaller
phones so it is still somehow we expect
the DP make the text a kind of um
independent of resolution by the same
time if the user decide to scale it up
for our for accessibility reasons are
there is an extra scaling factor of four
for user about to specify and after all
these um so I hope by now you have a
kind of a good graphs of what if he is
and and because of all these like um
problem with pixel and and and that's
why we kind of introduce a new size
qualifier
onto to do resource a classification and
and this new qualifiers allows more
control over on different specific like
screen sizes to support an application
so the O's size qualifier which is a
small normal medium large extra large
and um turns out because of the
resolution issue on is no longer good
enough to to classify by things like
tablets so in forum for example or
7-inch tablets as a size large but but
so that so that makes actually tablet
not necessary equal to an extra-large
which is a love which brings along
things and by introducing on these new
qualifiers so there are three of them so
one of them we call it a smallest width
so there is in Texas way SW and then and
then the number and then fep so um so
the nice things about this smaller width
is you don't need to care about are the
orientation of of your device so all all
us all you are specifying here it is on
for a particular device for the smallest
with our side of the tablet on all the
device it has to be at these six hundred
DP in this case so in that case the
resource under this of this resource
folder will be selected for creating
your layer pound on rendering the layout
on there are two other qualifiers one is
specific playful with and ll14 height
but it's tricky because um it really ups
to the OEM defined which which sized
with and besides the height and and we
usually is
see and recommend people using the
smallest width and then that should take
it take care of a lot of the cases um so
one thing about compatibility so um
before we introduce our before our
honeycomb 3.2 um these qualifier doesn't
make sense right so in that case we
still recommend developer especially
your targeting pre honeycomb devices and
you still need to specify a bucket to
other um to take care of like um
selecting our tablets are using extra
large for example but in this case um
there's one problem you can as you can
see there are two files are actually are
having the same tablet layout the main
activity XML is actually duplicate so
how to solve this problem so one thing
you can do is you can abstract out on
the tablet layout into intuitive and
they are using a different name or in
this case on coin main activity tablet
that I xml and for in your in your
enough in your willpower resource folder
under the are using values you can
specify layout arm pointing to that
particular xml so i understand like the
layout XML is still are duplicates but
you your content your you're truthful
layout is only define once so which is
the key here um finally let's talk a
little bit about our screen support so
in we have our two tags in in the
android framework to
to some to allow a multiple screen
support so one of them is support screen
and in this case here I want to filter
out a small and normal screen size so
this is the kind of the the
specification I need to do to set a
small screen and a normal screen tip
force so how about this one so uh is is
this the configuration to the filter out
smoke only make your your application
available for small or normal sized
screen well that turns out the answer is
wrong because or support screen that
doesn't mean your application will not
be available but for large and extra
large device it just mean that they're
running in something we call
compatibility mode for these are for
these two form factors so so how to
filter out a large or extra large screen
device then um we have another tag
actually can can really do this so in
this case here you're using something
called compatibles intact and you have
to specify all the screen you you you
you would like to support so that's the
one big caveat and and that's end up a
ton of the reason why we are not
recommending developer to to use this
because you if you don't specify all the
all the different combination your
application we will not be available for
those you didn't specify and another
thing is after all are in android me we
always want looking for the advocate
application that support all devices and
that should be your ultimate goal um so
that's pretty much for our pas density
independent pixel and
so we can switch to Q&A or encourage you
anything to add to this feel free to
chime you know that was a was quite
comprehensive cool so at this stage I
guess we can given that we've just had a
topic that we've the attorneys presented
are there any questions on the on the
presentation from any of the the live
audience or anyone tuning into the
streaming yeah hi I would like to ask
about pictures and images loaded from
the internet for example Facebook so if
Facebook has a large image say 180
pixels on large devices with hdpi they
will be displayed as twice so it will be
like 90 DPI anyway to any strategies to
like scale them oh so so I think that in
that case is like that is the
presentation is if you define your image
our dimension using DP the android
framework will automatically actually
scale good that you make up image up for
you but then again you run into the
issue of our interpolation you may you
will not have a perfect image and that's
why we suggest developer to creative and
access are in the right resolution for
for for the particle density as a just
general strategy though if you're
pulling on in your situation you said
you were pulling down assets from the
net and you might not have you know
different resolutions of those images
consider whether you you think stretch
stretching that image is really the
right thing to do and certainly consider
whether you want to stretch it to as big
as you can get there might be a middle
ground that makes more sense like you
know 1.5 times in every dimension where
it doesn't look too
blurry but you know it is what it is so
if your source images low resolution
there's only so much that you're going
to be able to do with it thank you um
there was a question there was a couple
of questions on moderator that have been
added Tony on this topic so that's let's
let's deal with those ones first then
today is it possible and how to provide
different graphics except nine pages for
two different devices running for
example at 800 x 480 and 540 x 960 on
android too and 2.3 without checking the
resolution via java source and setting
the proper graphics so my understanding
of this question as a person asking how
do i make it scale without having to
manually do it myself is that your
understanding Tony oh yeah so based on
what well what the question doing that
yeah so what I would suggest is actually
just I mean if you if you're just going
to render it in a view just use the like
an imageview just use the properties
that we provide their that allow that
where you can specify whether you want
it to to stretch to fit or you want to
descale or you want to do crop there's a
couple of options there that you should
really have a look at and see what makes
sense so in that case the the android
framework is doing the work for you so
just keep in mind however though as I as
we just said to Constantine that it may
not make sense to always you know
stretch your low res image to a bigger
so in terms of providing the best user
experience because that's that's that
that's the goal at the end of the day
you might have to have some logic in
there that says hey if I'm pulling down
some some image from from an online
source and I don't know what what
resolution it will be do I want to make
it bigger than it is or do I want to
shrink it so on and so forth if you're
providing your own assets
as long as you're kind of reasonably in
the ballpark I would probably try and
render the image slightly higher than it
needs to be and then put it in the in
the relevant resolution bucket and then
just sighs my UI based on dps just like
Tony described today yeah um I think the
second question we have on moderator is
when whenever we read the dimension of
device screen example voy deep kind 800
1024 x 600 in the device specification
is that value in pixel DP 0 gie so oh
well oh my- standings tho those number
in pixel and and and also another thing
is DP and div are the same thing yeah so
I think that was a trick question to try
and catch us out turning so we get it up
yeah yeah and one thing i want you i
want to comment is when we've talked
about like designing layout in DP is
really what we are talking about is um
we want experience on on on a particular
physical size consistent regardless of
resolution so so so we are not saying
like the using DP in your layout will
will will still at properly in different
size of device that's natural is the
museum is a misconception so what we are
talking about here is if you design a
7-inch layout 47 inch device and if you
are specifying all these dimension in DP
it will guarantee to work on all the do
all the seven inches devices um with
other software solution and that's just
the power of TP it's not we are not
saying like if it is a 15-7 janeiro
using DP it will work in the 10 inch
device that's not true and you have what
you should do is you should define a
layer
for attend attend for a change in form
factor and you may choose to have like
using more famine or different design
and things should be still done in DP so
that are your layer will work on 10
inches divided with different resolution
so that's the that's the key to key
concept here yeah might just add to that
Tony and in general I my experience has
been that 7-inch devices and 10-inch
devices you can actually reuse the same
layout in general and it and it works
really well and it scales nicely I mean
assuming you're building nice scalable
user interfaces one big differentiating
factor that I find between seven inch
tablets and 10-inch tablets however is
that the default orientation of a
10-inch tablet is landscape mode whereas
the default orientation of most of the
just about all the 7-inch tablets I've
seen his portrait mode so that's
something that you should consider as to
you know how what you lay out how your
layer might change between portrait mode
and landscape mode so to me the big
differentiating factor is actually the
the orientation as opposed to the
physical size of the screen right anyway
I mean like if if you if you do things
like right using like silk on our field
parents or Comicon of for the deep for
the container so things will flow
properly when you go from a 7-inch the
tens 10 20 10 inch device but the but
one thing to remember is if you specify
things in DP those assets or controls
will stay the same size regardless of
the in 7 inch or 10 inch so um but if
you do the container or layer container
properly and they will they will give us
us or doing using percentage and then
we'll things will work fine so yeah so I
think that's that's all the questions
that we had on this this week's topic so
Tony thanks for covering DPS the one
we talked about was sort of the
advantages of DP but the big takeaway I
think developers should really go go
back with is don't use pixels in your
layout right don't specify user
interfaces with pixels because that is
not going to scale across the wide
ecosystem of devices that we have and
you know build scalable user interfaces
and DPS are certainly one way to do that
and the other way of building sort of
flexible user interfaces is using things
like wrap content or feel parent on on
your on your layouts as well all right
so we've got three other questions on
here Tony and I'll just take them from
the top I'm implementing in-app billing
but when i try to buy some item in the
sample app i don't get a response from
my app and after a few minutes i get an
error of reason took too long to deliver
this bug was in the known issues for
almost a year is there an update I
didn't know it was a known issue and
certainly I've played within our billing
and I haven't had this particular issue
so I don't know if you've got more dad
to anybody be great if this person brn I
would um contact us separately and just
just let us know what the ish you know
if he's got a he or she have a bug
raised I am not aware that there is a
bug but one thing that may cost that
reason took too long didn't deliver is
um some of the transaction of orders is
actually maybe black as as fraud or
anomalous engine and and so so I think
one thing I developer should have
expectation is there there are certain
percentage of our orders that will be my
black ass like potential risk fraud so
and and for those ordering will it will
not process go through and and and
that's the result of could be resolved
that long
to talk too long and it shouldn't it
shouldn't happen in the test after
because if he's using he or she are
using that sample app it's a you should
be using the package names that are
using the the test nomenclature so okay
the risk engine side shouldn't come into
play but I'd love it so from the day are
they are developers lame are telling
like some transaction of fouling and so
may not be this case here but but that
could be a potential problem sometimes
if you see transaction didn't go through
it I hate to say this normal but the but
it does happen I some some transaction
does won't go through for risk reason
yeah cool so please do contact Tony on
myself and I will would we can have a
deeper dive in it I guess we need to see
a little bit more as to exactly what
you're doing then we can try and take
from there okay according to the google
cloud messaging tutorial wakelock is
required in order to handle the
registration action how can the device
handle registration response but in
sleep mode when sending requests to a
third-party server any other examples of
services requiring a wakelock I I know
an example so we have a an open source
project or chrome to phone and and and
and there should be implementation on
the things you described um in terms of
getting handle reservation responding in
sleep mode and Cardinals do you have any
insight on this this part no I mean in
general I think it's good practice to to
a to acquire the wakelock if you're
waiting for a response because these
things your request responses are
asynchronous in nature so if you
actually want to make sure that you are
you know awake so to speak
for that duration then you should do so
just be careful in terms of acquiring
that way clock because you want to try
and minimize how long you've got it for
because of course the the device is not
able to sleep at that point in time so
it's a drain on the battery yeah green
um so the third question last question
oh you have a question yeah I'd like to
add more about this question for example
I have a foreground service which uses
WebSocket connection to the server and
definitely the user can push the power
button to for device to go sleep on does
it mean that I still need to acquire
wake look or so so the connection won't
be broken if you want to maintain the
persistence of your connection then i
would recommend yes but I would also ask
you to really think about whether that
connection needs to be persistent
persisted throughout and that's that's
one of the benefits of google cloud
messaging right so you don't have to you
don't have to have a wakelock the whole
time or a connection to your server you
can have a notification comforter or a
message come through and then you can
spring to action then it's event based
rather than you having to maintain this
persistent connection ok all right so
the last last question we have here is
can you recommend the best way to
implement themes in android since you
point to cover DPI and other related
topics maybe consider having a mean for
about arm about 20 lakhs so first of all
that's a crystal gestures and I think
like that theme itself could be another
ad out plus presentation so definitely
will look into that and and hopefully we
have another session about themes
specifically in the future yep
yeah in the meantime though we've
actually got a fairly extensive section
in the on developer.android.com in the
guide section on styles and themes and I
walks walks you through sort of how to
style do some basic styling I think
that's a great place to get started
there there are more sort of
community-based examples that I've seen
that they go to a larger extent so I'd
seen a community effort for building the
holo theme for older Android versions
for example so what I'd suggest is start
with this guide and then go have a look
at some of these community efforts and
see how people are building and building
advanced theme so to speak but yes
thanks for the suggestion I think that's
a good idea for a future topic as well
yeah ah ok well anyone else have any
questions um I had one yeah yeah go
ahead yeah go ahead be me over ok yeah
there are no it in you yep and I just
have wife in the chat window that when
i'm using sort of nine patches do i need
to specify a PNG file for each of their
different DPI buckets or do i just need
to have one in my drawer folder that
will cover me for everything I think you
could get away with just having the one
I wouldn't put it in the drawable folder
we actually have one called the drawable
dash no DPI which is kind of like the
explicit one to say that this applies to
every bucket and why I mean it will work
but just from a best practices point of
view we recommend using the the no DPI
non culture cool yeah I think I think
using nine petrus thought I it can be
another topic Oh in future I can talk
about you I just want to make sure that
I didn't need to have sort of a high res
nine patch for high-res devices and a
sort of low res welfare potentially you
can actually depend how big the images
right yeah
if you're doing it for styling you know
you I then maybe you can get away
without it but if you're doing you know
high-res images that you're expecting to
stretch is back down button just things
like buttons and stuff like that so at
the moment I've been kind of using
defining them in XML using gradients and
stuff and strokes so that I don't have
to have a nine patch instead and that
seems to work quite well but I was just
thinking if I needed a more fancy button
that couldn't be defined using a
gradient then am I to use nine pitchers
yeah you probably I mean ideally you
should have you should be building
assets for each of those really each of
those buckets but if it's something
really small like like your nine patch
is really tiny then you know might be
overkill um there is no I don't think
that it's an exact science so you kind
of have to use your judgment as to what
what at what point you should sort of
break the cord and say now I do need to
build a specific name badges for each of
those buckets cool Cheers yes alright
we've just had one other person join and
yeah I'm gonna one more question about
the layout yeah absolutely so going back
to my question some question about
images from from that for example if I
have an image 1 and 80 pixels width so
is it the best option to set the maximum
width for like g1 devices point DPI
otherwise it will be like more than a
half screen width and leave it as is
480p I devices in the image view so just
just so I make sure that I understood
your question do you mean whether you
should scale the image down or shrink it
so that it's not occupying too much
physical space on the device yeah yeah i
would i would definitely do that i would
shrink it where possible i mean when it
makes sense so there is there is some
work that you need to do if you if you
holding assets from some remote server
that you you know whose resolution you
don't have any control over as to what
makes sense for your UI so if it only
makes sense for your you know whatever
it is to be only thirty percent of the
width of the screen then that's going to
you know that thirty percent the actual
number of the size of it is going to
differ regard depending on which device
you're running on right so yeah
absolutely you'd want to scale that it
said you didn't like linear linear
layouts can help there because you can
set weights and so on and have it done
for you but if you really depends our
custom built your UI is and how much
control you're exerting awkward is that
what the the scale type is for on the
image you now to say Center Theater
Center crop can ask yep that's exactly
right yeah but on top of that if if so
if you're doing it based on weights then
you need the linear layout weights to
come through as well over and above that
right but the scale type will definitely
say hey if you know my view is bigger
than the image then what should I do
with it so yeah thanks all right well if
there is nothing else thank you for
joining us this week I suspect that we
are actually going to we're not going to
run the ad or plus next week because of
a scheduling conflict but we will be
back soon and yeah again keep the
feedback coming we've had quite a few
suggestions for topics that we should
cover in the future and we are we are
definitely taking that on board and
prioritizing accordingly oh hello oh hi
there I go can I have one question one
more question yeah absolutely I'm the
guy with the in-app billing problem you
responded before oh and I have one
question oh my first my first payment
was from a credit card where I don't
have enough money and yes it can be
problem when I at one another
car and after all some more payments
I've got cancellation of this payment
can it be a dose problem if you
understand yeah sorry tourney do you
want to grab this this one uh I can I
can show you oh it's um screen share
yeah so just be careful about showing
any of your credit card details good
that won't be a good thing linea said
maybe we can do this off of wine you can
you can I can show that's no problem no
I don't think we should actually I think
it's better than every day let's do it
yeah okay gonna come when it comes to
payment that sort of stuff can be quite
sensitive so what I suggest is look like
we'll we'll wrap up the idea plus here
and let's solve your attorney and I will
contact you straight afterwards and will
continue our discussion through that
okay thank you thank you thank you
everyone thank you